on a cold october night in 2003
shirley yates of seattle washington was
just about to get ready for bed when she
heard a knock at the door
she approached the door and asked the
person on the other side to identify
themselves
the voice outside responded immediately
it was a salesman who just wanted a few
moments of mrs yates time
this was odd for two reasons first it
was almost 10 o'clock at night
much later than as usual for
door-to-door salesmen and
second the knock hadn't come from mrs
yates's front door
it was coming from the door to her
bathroom has your home ever been visited
by a door-to-door salesman
if you were born in the last 40 years
then your answer to that question is
probably
no in the age of online shopping the
idea of a salesperson going from house
to house hawking vacuum cleaners or
encyclopedia sets feels like a relic
from the past
it's highly unlikely you'd ever see one
walking the streets nowadays
and equally unlikely that one would
knock on your front door
however if you live in washington state
you might need to be wary of a certain
salesman who is still
doing the rounds scp-1879
also known as the indoor salesman and
the doorman
is a phenomenon that manifests randomly
in homes throughout washington
subjects will hear persistent knocking
from the interior doors of their homes
and the affected door becomes classified
as scp-1879-1
the knocking doesn't stop until the door
is opened at which point the subject
will be greeted by
scp-1879-2 a caucasian man of
indeterminate age
standing around 170 centimeters tall
the man will claim to be a salesman and
immediately try to pitch a bizarre
product to the subject whose home he's
just
invaded the scp foundation was first
alerted to the existence of the indoor
salesman when they had intercepted a
home of 911 shirley yates she had opened
the door to her bathroom in an attempt
to get the salesman to stop
knocking and once he was in her home he
refused to leave
according to yates he kept disappearing
in and out of random doors in her house
foundation field agent rogers was
equipped with a recording device and
sent
in to investigate the case with several
other agents
when he arrived at the home he found mrs
yates inconsolable
scp-1879-2 was still rapidly talking at
her
and strangely enough the product he was
holding and trying to sell to her
was a border collie puppy as soon as
agent rogers entered the room the man
shifted his attention away from mrs
yates and towards him
he then started trying to sell the puppy
to agent rogers
agent rogers did not want to purchase
this puppy but he found that the man
spoke so quickly and
urgently he couldn't get a word in
edgewise
the man was begging rogers to take the
puppy practically shoving it in his face
saying that he didn't need any money and
that the only payment he needed would be
some of your time rogers grew so annoyed
at being talked over and interrupted
that he ordered the other field agents
to apprehend the indoor salesman
they did so but as soon as the agents
walked him out of the front door of the
house
he disappeared without a trace the
agents remained in the area to monitor
the situation
scp-1879-2 manifested again in mrs
yates's home
six hours later still trying to trade
the puppy for no money
just a little of her time 12 years to be
precise
after hours and hours of being worn down
by this supernaturally pushy salesman
yates relented and agreed to take the
puppy
and immediately disappeared the indoor
salesman then disappeared himself
through the closet door before he could
be apprehended again
at a loss for what to do the agents
administered class a amnestics to mrs
yates's family
and left the reason for her
disappearance wasn't fully known until
12 years later in 2015 when she
reappeared in the same spot she
disappeared from
having no concept of how much time had
passed
the puppy really had just cost her 12
years of her life
stories like that of shirley yates have
popped up all over the state in the
years since
from everett to walla walla and
everywhere in between
due to the random nature of scp-1879
events and the way the indoor salesman
can disappear
instantly in and out of any door in the
building the scp foundation has been
unable to capture him
the best they've been able to do is
monitor 9-1-1 calls from across the
state
listening for key words that might
indicate another
scp-1879 infestation
when such an event is reported the
foundation deploys mobile task force row
4
aka shoe salesman this task force's
entire purpose is to minimize the amount
of harm the indoor salesman is able to
cause by
intercepting him before he can make a
sale this
is a very important task as evidenced by
the story of mrs yates
since while the products this salesman
sells might be innocent
he doesn't accept payment in any normal
currency
the price he has for his products are
always bizarre and often deadly
if all someone loses his 12 years of
their life they could be considered to
be getting off easy
in one instance the product being sold
was a single red rose
in exchange for the subject's heart once
the deal was sealed
the subject dropped dead on the spot
with an autopsy revealing that his heart
and circulatory system
vanished from inside his body in another
the indoor salesman offered 220 bananas
and told the subject to simply
give him some sugar the subject agreed
and all
candied goods in the home disappeared in
a third the indoor salesman was trying
to sell a thermonuclear warhead
the price of which was the subject's
soul the subject accepted
and at first nothing seemed to have
happened the foundation confiscated the
warhead and placed it into non-anomalous
containment
later that day the subject went to
listen to some music
only to find that two of her vinyl
records had gone missing
lady soul and almighty fire by world
famous soul singer
aretha franklin so even though he's
incredibly invasive
annoying and his transactions can be
deadly
the indoor salesman still maintains a
sense of humor
the fact that the foundation can't
capture the indoor salesman means that a
lot of questions about him remain
unanswered the biggest by far is why he
does
what he does in most scp-1879 events
the indoor salesman seems frantic and
desperate to make a sale
often he will refer to having quotas and
deadlines to meet
which implies some other unseen entity
that he has to answer to
these questions remain unanswered
because all attempts to interrogate the
indoor salesman have been unsuccessful
when he manifests in the location it's
impossible to get him to stray from a
sales pitch
and he disappears as soon as he
successfully sells his wares
however there was one instance where
after an scp-1817
event took place foundation agents were
there to witness a rare interaction
between the indoor salesman and his
mysterious
employers agent rogers and the rest of
the shoes salesmen were called out to a
home in spokane
where rapid knocking had begun to
emanate from the bedroom door
equipped with recording devices rogers
was able to record the voice of the
indoor salesman coming from inside the
bedroom
in the recording the salesman grumbled
to himself about not being able to meet
his quota by tomorrow
saying that if he didn't he'd be stuck
in this world for the next century
he started knocking again yelling
through the door that he knew
they were home he kept knocking until he
was interrupted by the sound of a phone
ringing
the indoor salesman was heard picking it
up and rogers managed to record the
conversation
the person calling was apparently the
indoor salesman's boss
who was calling to complain about his
performance only one side of the
conversation was
heard but evidently the indoor
salesman's boss wasn't too happy about
receiving two
aretha franklin albums as payment
instead of an actual human soul
the indoor salesman apologized for the
joke then told his boss
it won't happen again please don't hurt
it i'll meet the quota this time i swear
he hung up grumbling to himself again i
better get to move up to a lease
accounting this time
i've paid my dues and then some rogers
finally opened the door to the apparent
disappointment of the indoor
salesman who was hoping to speak with
the home's owner and was quite annoyed
at having another one of his sales
interrupted by mtf
row 4. rogers tried to ask the indoor
salesman who he'd just been speaking to
on the phone
but as usual the salesman started
talking over him
now see here let's think logically he
said you know i'm not going to tell you
anything
i know you're not likely to buy what i'm
selling so let's just move on to greener
pastures
i'm coming up close to a deadline and
i'm sure you're swamped with making sure
good people don't lose their job so i'll
just be on my way and let you do that
ciao the indoor salesman tried to close
the door but agent rogers blocked it
with his arm
he was tired of this scp giving him the
runaround
and he was going to keep the indoor
salesman here if it was the last
thing he did he demanded the entity stay
and be interviewed
and other members of the task force
apprehended the salesman making sure he
couldn't leave the room
the indoor salesman now held in place by
several armed men
seemed to finally relend he told rogers
i'm busy so i'll tell you what
i'm gonna give you something no money
out of your pocket and we'll call it
even sound good
rogers just wanting to get this whole
thing over with agreed to those terms
three seconds later every agent on the
scene was dead
and the indoor salesman was able to
straighten his tie pick up his briefcase
and walk through the door to the
bathroom
when the bodies of agent rogers and the
rest of the mtf row 4 were examined by
foundation scientists
the cause of death was found to be in
every case
thousands of coins suddenly appearing in
not only their pockets
but also inside their stomachs lungs and
even under their skin later that day the
indoor salesman was reported at a home
in the same neighborhood
he was seen trying to sell the house's
owner 80 year old retiree alan johnson
a glock 18 pistol in exchange for his
attention
as he had done so many times before the
indoor salesman disappeared through
another door
before the foundation was able to reach
the scene and when the scp arrived
they found mr johnson still alive but
now missing his prefrontal cortex
the part of the brain that controls
attention it's likely that
because of the nature of the entity
scp-1879 might be entirely impossible to
contain
the foundation might never find out
anything more than what they already
know about the indoor salesman
the way he's able to manifest behind
closed doors
or the reason he has to keep filling
quotas for an unseen boss
who apparently doesn't have a very good
sense of humor
so if you're ever in washington state be
careful who you open your doors to
especially if the knocking you hear is
coming from inside
your house but now if we could have just
a few moments of your time we've got
something real special for you
it's scp-001 which is the real zero zero
one this is a thirty for one deal that
you can't pass up so go watch
now